- So what were you like as a kid,
were you both talkative?
'Cause you're both, even
though you might not
be a stand up comedian,
you're a very comedic
actor, so were y'all,
and you're very friendly.
Were y'all both like this as kids?
- Where'd you grow up?
- Pittsburgh.
- Oh, got you.
- You?
- Long Island.
- Everyone cool is from Long Island.
(applause)
- Really?
- That's cool.
- I didn't know that.
- Yeah, Long Island, New
Jersey, that whole area.
But were y'all always this talkative?
Or were you introverts when you were kids?
- I was talkative.
My brother and I, my brother
Eliot is also a comedian.
We would make sketch videos for hours,
- [Kelly] That's cool.
and hours and hours.
I've always been a comedy
nerd, and that's it.
- That's awesome.
- That's all I am.
- Were you always this talkative?
You knew everyone, right off the bat?
- No, no.
I was very, I was sort of,
I needed to be a good boy
in school, I made good grades,
and there was kind of a,
I was, you know, properly--
- [Kelly] Strict household?
- Huh?
- You said good little boy,
was it a strict household?
- They were kind of
strict, there was some kind
of serious demand that we be well behaved
in one area or another
and in school certainly
so I was kinda constrained.
So I, it was kind of an
outlet when I found myself,
I had to find my voice by
and by, as I'm still doing.
But I remember, I had a talent
for drawing and painting
and my dad would take us
to this special art class, me every week.
And waiting outside the
Carnegie Melon Museum,
the Carnegie Museum.
- Wow.
- He hadn't shown up yet
and I would do this thing,
that I can't believe I
did, I was like 11 or 12,
I would see people and
then pretend to know them.
To go, "Oh my gosh, look who it is!"
- I think there's a word for
that, it's called stalker.
- It's strange.
- That's strange.
You were 14?
- Yeah, 14 or 11 or 12
or something like that.
- What a bizarre level of
agency, to grown ups, to adults.
- Do you think it was to make
you feel more comfortable
that you were alone in that moment?
- I don't know, I think was me--
- Wow, someone goes to therapy, okay.
Okay, I see you Kelly Clarkson.
- Hashtag truth.